joining us now is the man at the center
of the story asking you to marason Abed
who is a Republican in Berkeley
California married Jesse a regula thank
you both so much I should note that the
Berkeley mayor is a Democrat who
supports sanctuary policies but first I
want to go to you mayor I bet you had
took an oath of office office as a
citizen coming to this country as an
immigrant explain to me how that plays
into your decision tonight to be against
the sanctuary laws coming out of San
Francisco Sacramento well I took the
oath twice Katie what first when I
became citizen in 1990 and then second
time when I was elected councilman in
2004 and last time when I was elected
mayor in 2010 I came to this country to
keep my family safe and I see myself
here fighting for the safety of my
families and and the families of his
Candido I represent 150,000 of our
residents our relationship with eyes
have worked perfectly the ice agent has
made my case and we have deported over
2,000 illegal criminals from our city
with our cooperation with ice and we
focus on criminals only now the ice
agents are on their own in the community
in our neighborhood at our stations
transit stations picking up criminals
and innocent people as a result of our
cooperation with ice the crime in
Escondido went down by 33% Escondido
today as safe as it was in 1980 I was
elected mayor to uphold the Constitution
and also to keep my community safe this
resolution to fight the state
essentially law is at the core of my
mission so mayor I recommend I want to
get your response to that because the
the mayor of Escondido is saying here
that they had 2000 criminal aliens that
they have deported from their community
which would be on the streets if
Sacramento had its way by banning local
law enforcement from working with the
federal government what do you have to
say about that why should 2000 criminal
aliens still be in in these communities
well I think it's important too
define what you mean by criminal because
certainly a violation of federal civil
immigration law is a crime are we
talking about people that are violent
criminals or people that are just the
victims of a broken immigration system
and certainly Escondido they have a
right to take positions on issues that
are important to their community but
Escondido doesn't speak for Berkeley and
they don't speak for the state of
California and there are many cities
throughout the Bay Area and the state of
California that believe that sanctuary
policies make community safer for
example in my city crime has gone down
the last ten years and even with our
sanctuary policy our police are still
cooperating with federal agencies there
was an operation in my city a couple
weeks ago where Homeland Security
Investigations arrested an illegal
illegal immigrant who was engaged in in
drug crime it's nice that the local
police at Berkeley are trying to stop
illegal criminal aliens with those kinds
of crimes but if we want to get into the
details of what defines as criminal
Governor Jerry Brown just pardoned
five criminal aliens with violent
records like domestic violence theft
robbery armed robbery carrying out
crimes with a handgun
I mean mayor Abed Abed what is your
response to other municipalities
allowing these criminal aliens to
continue to operate inside California
because they can just drive down to
where you are it's not like there's a
border absolutely I think this is a risk
not only to Escondido but to every city
in California and every state in the
nation this mayor is in denial they want
to give sanctuary to illegal criminals
giving sanctuary is to leave illegal
criminals and giving them more rights
and protect their rights more than the
citizen is just immoral it's illegal is
unconstitutional we need to keep our
community safe
sb 52 the sanctuary state will give the
immigrants the legal immigrants and
illegal immigrants less protection
because ice is going to be in our
neighborhoods picking up everyone this
is just insane this is immoral and I
cannot understand who anybody who
anybody would give the
illegal criminals protection from the
law and treat and more rights than than
than giving to the citizens it's just
unbelievable california is emotional
cover nur brown and and them the mayor's
the progressive mayor's and the
legislature have lost sight of doing the
right thing well Maribeth you're not
alone i want to pull up this map of
other cities and municipalities counties
who are looking at either pushing back
against sacramento or already have
there's almost a more than a dozen of
them at this point
so clearly local communities are looking
at that and saying we don't want to be
part of these these laws that don't
allow local law enforcement to work with
the feds but going back to mr. white
arregui for just a moment what do you
have to say to those who are victims of
crimes of criminal aliens who are
allowed to be out on the streets now
because these new sanctuary state laws
allow them to them to escape ice and
recommit crimes well my response to that
is we have undocumented residents who
are somebody who is a documented that
lives in our communities an illegal
alien that's that's the commit you may
choose to define them that way i'm
referring them as undocumented okay so
that our immigration process is so
flawed that it takes years for people to
actually get citizenship status we have
to remember that we're a nation of
immigrants yeah here little Asian reform
to actually fix the process so people
can't legally become citizens because
you're arguing that in America the
United States of America the most
generous country in the world people are
unable to become citizens and to take
the oath of office to stand up for the
Constitution in the United States the
man who was debating you tonight mayor
Abed did that he did that for his
country so for you to say that it's
impossible to get citizenship just is
not on par with the facts Mehrabad do
you want to respond it's offensive it's
clearly offensive you know they are
giving my dog my two daughters went
through the university of calcium our
cause we paid full tuition illegal
immigrants pay less tuition in the in
the states in the end of the school
system they are giving more rights not
only educationally financially they are
harboring them now they're giving them
more rights they lost track
I think the Democrat I think this
Sacramento Governor Brown and our mayor
here on on this show they lost track
they are really emotional about the
administration in the last election and
their emotion and their this is a
clouding their good judgment of doing
the right thing there is a disconnect
between them and their constituents I
think you're going to see a pushback I
think this the number of cities against
the sanctuary state is gonna grow and
it's gonna grow and I think there is a
movement I am very proud to lead this
effort Mary Reagan you get the final
word well I'll just say that I do
believe that sanctuary cities make
community safer
victims of domestic violence I see
crimes they're more likely to report
those crimes and seek the seek the
intervention of police that they know
that they're not going to be deported
and in Oakland in the Bay Area where
there are recent raids and arrests of
people that were undocumented half of
those people had no had no violent or
criminal record I think I'll take issue
with the fact they're not allowed to
break the law illegal aliens are
constantly shielded from the law in
California which is why cities and
counties like Escondido are fighting
back Mara regula and mayor of a they're
proud to be a sanctuary City